[Musique]
la semaine et pas que politique
sous le regard de françois xavier
bellamine mon invité bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes tête de liste l'est
républicain aux élections européennes
d'abord est ce que le responsable
politique et le catholique pratiquant me
semble utile que vous êtes est satisfait
de la manière dont notre dame a été
célébrée si j'ose dire
des hommages qui ont été rendu à la
cathédrale notre dame cette semaine ce
qui est très beau c'est la vraie unité
qu'on a vécu au sein de notre pays et
même d'ailleurs au delà autour de ce
lieu effectivement magnifique
effectivement symbolique de ce que nous
sommes et auxquels nous avons été
rappelés par les preuves que nous avons
tous ressenti en voyant les images de
cet incendie
et je crois que cette unité elle est
précieuse et il faut bien sûr
effectivement pouvoir faire en sorte
qu'elles vivent et qu'elle dure
nous pouvons avoir des désaccords nous
pouvons avoir des divergences mais est
réunie autour de ce qui nous constitue
de ce qui fait notre culture commune
c'est je crois très précieux et c'était
nécessaire d'être unis pour pouvoir dire
en particulier notre reconnaissance
envers les pompiers qui ont sauvé ce
lieu ce lieu décisif il y à l'unité
populaire l'union nationale et la trêve
politique qui a prévalu pendant quelques
jours et puis vous notamment avait
décoché quelques flèches à l'endroit des
manuels macron la dernière étant celle
selon laquelle d'après vous emmanuel
macron n'a pas eu lors de son adresse à
la nation mardi soir à meaux pour les
catholiques si vous le permettez
écoutons quand même ce qu'a dit le
président de la république
lundi soir c'est tout premiers mots
quasiment furent lorsqu'il s'est rendu
sur le parvis de la cathédrale
notre-dame encore en feu ces mots pour
la communauté où tu veux ce soir avoir
bien entendu avant tout
une pensée pour les catholiques les
catholiques de france et partout à
travers le monde en particulier en cette
semaine sainte
je sais ce qu'ils ressentent et nous
sommes avec eux n'auriez-vous pas pu
économiser une petite polémique françois
xavier bellamy je n'avais pas du tout
l'intention de déclencher une polémique
je suis assez frappé de l'ampleur que
prennent les choses ce matin chez l'un
de vos confrères j'ai eu l'occasion de
dire en effet que je regrettais qu
emmanuel macron lors de son allocution
officielle depuis l'elysée mais
effectivement dans le temps qu'il a
consacré à cet événement important et
dont j'ai dit que je lui étais
reconnaissant qu'il n'est pas pourtant
mentionné la communauté des catholiques
qui effectivement est directement touché
par cet incendie
il avait la veille au soir dans les
grandes largeurs si j'ose dire je me
suis contenté de le regretter comme j'ai
regretté que christophe castaner dans
son allocution officielle au moment de
l'hommage qui a été rendu à l'hôtel de
ville de paris n'est pas non plus
mentionné cela je crois que quand un
lieu comme celui ci brûle
évidemment nous sommes tous touchés je
suis le premier à dire depuis le début
de cette campagne que le piège du
communautarisme qui menace de se
refermer sur nous doit être absolument
éviter cela étant dit quand un lieu
comme celui-là brûle il touche
directement en l'occurrence les
chrétiens les catholiques au coeur de
cette semaine sainte et il me semble que
tous les maux premier mot débat de
mariage lorsqu'il se rend à notre maman
que danser lundi soir vous vous dites
pas trop la polémique mais vous n'êtes
pas un politique comme les autres vous
êtes tête de liste les républicains pour
les européennes l'un de ces géologique
qui monte je n'ai dit on vous savez que
vos mots ont du poids bien sûr mais je
répète ce que j'ai dit je regrette c'est
vrai je ne reviens pas du tout là dessus
que dans cette allocution officielle
dans ces moments solennels qui ont un
poids particulier justement qu'on n'ait
pas mentionné les chrétiens je ne suis
pas le seul à le dire d'ailleurs
l'archevêque de paris que vous voyez ici
a lui aussi dit cela il a lui aussi dit
son regret que le mot catholique n'ait
pas été prononcé et quand je vois
l'ampleur de la pole de la polémique qui
est fait depuis ce matin par la
déclaration quand je vois que certains
m'attaque comme si j'avais commis des
faits que news alors que je me suis
contenté de dire très précisément ce que
je viens de vous dire et dont je ne
retire pas un mot je crois
qu'effectivement peut-être parfois pour
certains le mot catholique est un peu un
gros mot je le regrette je crois qu'on
devrait pouvoir simplement partager
ensemble de petites réserves comme celle
ci sans qu'on en fasse immédiatement un
débat gigantesque jeu
et absolument rien dit qu'ils soient
inexactes je n'ai absolument rien dit
qui soit non plus inutilement polémique
j'ai même dit ce matin encore ma
reconnaissance au président de la
république qui je crois effectivement a
eu les gestes qu'il fallait lorsqu'il
est venu sur le parvis de notre dame de
paris
ça n'enlève rien à ce petit regret on
peut le partager ensemble sans en faire
toute une affaire
il ya donc eu cette parenthèse liée à l'
incendie qui a dévasté une partie de la
cathédrale de notre-dame et puis la vie
politique notamment en reprend son cours
la du social aussi il y à demain le 23e
samedi de mobilisation consécutif les
gilet jaune d'ailleurs et puis il ya ces
craintes évidemment des des autorités
qui craignent le retour des casseurs de
nouvelles violences soixante mille
policiers et gendarmes mobilisés demain
un petit peu partout en france
est ce que vous vous adressez encore une
fois vous êtes tête de liste les
républicains pour les européennes en
appel à ces gilets jaunes
je ne suis pas sûr que ceux qui ont
l'intention de venir casser et détruire
ceux susceptibles d'entendre quelques
appels que ce soit parle de villejoie de
ma part bien sûr que aujourd'hui ceux
qui ont transformé ce mouvement en ce
qu'il est devenu un rituel de désordre
organisé samedi après samedi qui
paralyse depuis si longtemps notre pays
ceux là n'ont rien à voir avec des
citoyens qui voudraient s'exprimer
pacifiquement la manifestation est un
droit dans notre pays
mais ce droit s'exerce dans les règles
constitutionnelles qui évidemment
doivent s'appliquer et aujourd'hui nous
n'avons plus affaire à une revendication
comme celle qui était formulée au tout
début du mouvement
devant seulement affaire à une espèce de
poussées de violence dont on a vu
effectivement qu'elle n'avait plus
d'autre but que de détruire et de casser
c'est un vrai problème qu'effectivement
nous ne soyons pas capables de remettre
de l'ordre dans notre pays il faut que
tout cela cesse pour que nous puissions
retrouver un débat qui soit apaisé les
gilet jaune redescendre dans la rue pour
le 23ème samedis consécutifs demain
comme si rien ne se passait et emmanuel
macron devait s'exprimer devant les
français lundi soir puis deux jours plus
tard s'exprimer lors d'une conférence de
presse répondre aux questions des
journalistes ce sera finalement jeudi
prochain on va y revenir
les annonces elles sont là elles ont
fuité on verra si les mesures sont
amendés mais est ce que vous comprenez
l'insatisfaction d'un certain nombre de
français qui porte le gilet jaune alors
même que certaines mesures sont
annoncées
encore une fois je ne suis pas sûr que
ceux qui manifestent aujourd'hui soit
exactement ce qu'ils manifestaient hier
au tout début de ce mouvement a été
exprimée par une partie de la société
française
des revendications qui nous paraissaient
qui nous paraissent toujours aujourd'hui
parfaitement légitime et notamment ce
que j'entends depuis le début de cette
campagne partout sur le terrain le
sentiment d' asphyxie que créer une
fiscalité parfois étouffante et ce
qu'ils gagnent encore à vos yeux dorés
descendre dans la rue alors bien sûr des
annonces ont passé sept ans en décembre
et en début de semaine ses patientes en
soirée d'annoncé mais en cadets ce que
devait dire emmanuel macron a fuité moi
je ne voudrais pas présumer de ce que
dira le président de la république je
crois simplement qu'il faut que nous
puissions avoir des réponses sur ces
sujets fondamentaux que sont la question
du pouvoir d'achat
la question dont le travail aujourd'hui
et troupes insuffisamment rémunérées
l'avenir dont beaucoup de français
travaillent et ne s'en sortent pas qui
est un vrai problème au coeur de notre
modèle social
et c'est sur tous ces sujets là que le
président de la république est attendu
j'espère que c'est sur ces sujets là
qu'il pourra répondre il ya des grandes
lignes qui ont donc fuite et je le
disais notamment des baisses d'impôts
pour les classes moyennes la
pérennisation de la prime gilet jaune
chaque année la réindexation des petites
retraites sur l'inflation
j'en cite quelques unes et évidemment le
président de la république a
manifestement également l'intention
d'augmenter la durée du temps de travail
parmi ces mesures il y en a qui me
semble-t-il regard des lignes
idéologiques des dernières décennies
pour être tout à fait convenir aux
leaders de la droite que vous êtes
nous nous avons fait des propositions
très concrètes pour la sortie du grand
débat et si le président de la
république en reprend évidemment nous ne
nous y opposerons pas bien fermé les
mesures que j'ai cités là et s'il y en a
qui vous satisfont pleinement le fait de
pouvoir enfin effectivement baisser les
impôts qui pèsent sur les français et je
pense en particulier à l'impôt sur le
revenu c'était évidemment une mesure
absolument nécessaire nous regrettons
encore une fois que tout ceci n'est pas
été entendu plus tôt si le gouvernement
et vous dites vous dit ça y est on y est
un petit peu là bien silva je ne sais
pas encore une fois ce que le président
de la république annoncera et je ne veux
pas présumer des déclarations qu'il fera
ce que je dis simplement c'est que si on
avait écouté les français plutôt on n'en
serait peut-être pas là aujourd'hui si
au moment où cette hausse de taxe a été
décidée au lieu de dire que c'était les
français qui rouler au diesel et qui
fumer des clopes on avait pris le temps
d'écouter ce qu'ils avaient à dire et
d'écouté notamment le désespoir de
beaucoup de ceux qui dans notre pays a
requise
agriculteurs pour travailler ont besoin
de carburant et qui ne parviennent pas à
déjà à s'en sortir si on les avait
entendus sans doute on n'en serait pas
arrivé à ce désordre qu'on connaît elles
sont les précisions essentielles que
vous attendez dans la bouche du chef de
l'état jeudi prochain lors de sa
conférence de presse à l'elysée à 18h
bien nous attendons qu'il puisse nous
dire dans quel cap il veut conduire la
france aujourd'hui malheureusement sur
concrètement sur sur les mesures là qui
ont fuité qui reste deux des grands axes
si je si j'ose dire mais on l'a où on
attend un mode d'emploi un peu plus
précis le mode d'emploi c'est qu'il faut
effectivement pouvoir baisser la
fiscalité qui pèse sur notre pays nous
sommes le pays champion du monde des
prélèvements obligatoires et donc il
faut baisser le poids de la pression
fiscale et pour ce faire il faut enfin
baisser le poids de la dépense publique
ce sont des chantiers de très grande
ampleur sur lesquelles malheureusement
rien n'a été encore réellement engagés
aujourd'hui il faut absolument que nous
puissions avoir une idée du cap vers
lequel nous nous dirigeons et permettez
moi de vous dire il faut aussi qu'on est
simplement de la clarté
parce que nous sommes dans un brouillard
qui dure depuis trop longtemps à voir
enfin la décision du président de la
république nous permettra aussi d'avoir
un vrai débat sur l'élection européenne
qui s'annonce est alors sélectionné il y
à cette colère d'une partie des français
certes un gilet jaune qui continuent à
descendre dans la rue
et puis il y a ce scrutin à venir les
élections européennes
les dernières études montrent que vous
les républicains alors que la liste la
république en marche et la liste du
rassemblement national sont au coude à
coude aux alentours d'une vingtaine de
2% d'intentions de vote vous stagner je
parle des dernières études et ce qui me
permet d'utiliser ce terme là aux
alentours de 13 très et demi pour cent
comment expliquez-vous que vous ne
d'écoliers pas d'accord nous sommes la
liste qui a connu la plus forte
progression depuis le début des enquêtes
d'opinion quand j'ai été investi à la
tête de cette liste avec agnès evren
avec arnaud danjean nous étions donnés à
8 % dans les sondages aujourd'hui
effectivement le dernier sondage nous
nous donne à 14%
cela étant dit vous savez moi je je
crois ce qui compte ce n'est pas de
faire de la politique l'oeil rivé sur
les sondages ce qui compte c'est de
partager une vision avec les fossés et
regarder les sondages quand même bien
sûr tout le monde les regarde mais ce
qui compte fondamentalement c'est de
faire le travail que nous faisons
aujourd'hui patiemment humblement de
faire un travail de terrain d'aller au
contact des français
lorsque je sens partout c'est qu'ils ont
envie qu'on leur parle d'europe on leur
propose des éléments très précis et très
concret ce que nous avons fait en
développement
un projet avec 75 propositions pour leur
dire l'europe que nous voulons au
service de la france qui a besoin
effectivement de se rétablir dans la
mondialisation etc ce débat là que que
nous devons vivre ensemble c'est moins
une question de sondage
au fond c'est même moins d'ailleurs une
question d'intérêt pour quelques
familles politiques que ce soit une
question vitale pour l'avenir de la
france
merci beaucoup françois-xavier bellamy
devra verser l'invitation de bfm ce taux